[Music]
welcome to the link online
hello I'm Mike Montgomery with Terry
Hague filling in for a Linda day on the
turn the crowd erupts around we got the
better ground and LaVon slug who's
filling in for a leash on I on the
Arctic but because Carlos is filling in
for LaVon but who can't be in the studio
right now so livan is essentially
killing in for himself yes I'm myself
here crowd erupts sounds like an
alligator your movement going up on this
edition of the link and I just want to
say hello to people watching on Facebook
live let us know where you are watching
us you can also write to us right into
the studio because our director leo no
you can't see is off camera I think
usually waves I don't know he's here you
can take your questions and we can try
to answer them or at least take them for
next week and try to answer them next
week anyway LaVon start us off what do
we have today we're going to walk
actually ancient rocks from the Arctic
will learn about what they can tell us
about the earth and the moon I have some
disturbing news a computer is probably
after your job even if you think it
couldn't do your job you're probably
wrong Secretary Theresa week and in just
a moment I'll tell you about the story
that karmel left for us it's about
Aboriginal leaders in Canada or speaking
out against the shipment of uranium from
Canada to the US and we'll have those
stories some of your comments and some
great community music on this edition of
the link online that's the thing button
yes that's what you get when you buy
your equipment at garage sales you know
budget cuts Terry start us off this time
okay well uranium now stored at the
nuclear facility at Chalk River Ontario
is to be transported seventeen hundred
kilometres to a facility in South
Carolina for processing they'd probably
say processing but okay in the United
States will go in the Canadian the plant
stems from a 2010 agreement that would
allow the United States to repatriate
the radioactive material which will
cause the Canadian government about 60
million beans us but a grow
chorus of protest over what many
consider to be the unsafe moves has been
building on both sides of the canada-us
border according to Gordon Edwards he's
the president of the Canadian Coalition
for nuclear responsibility just a tiny
amount of this toxic slew ending up in
one of the great lakes or in the st.
Lawrence River could ruin the drinking
water for many of the 40 million people
who live in the region First Nations
leaders are the latest group to object
to the transport plan the Iroquois
caucus will not accept 150 loads being
trucked from northwest of Ontario over
the border at a river crossing on or
near their territories Carmel kilkenny
spoke with gordon edwards to find out
more gunnlaug a grand chief joseph
norton talked about the processes to
down blend the liquid what is this and
can it be done at chopped liver yes down
blending is an alternative which would
prevent the necessity for transporting
this material at all because the only
justification that has been given for
moving it from spa day to spot be from
the Canada to the United States is the
presence in the mixture of weapons-grade
uranium this is uranium that is already
of such a high quality in such a high
concentration of uranium 235 that could
be used immediately in an atomic bomb or
explosive device in fact this is the
same grade of uranium that was used in
the Hiroshima bomb and there is an
initiative a very good one which we
applaud to eliminate the stockpiles of
this dangerous material highly enriched
uranium from all the countries that
currently possess it and also do not
have a bomb program and consequently do
not have the high security needed to to
safeguard it so this is just sitting in
storage around the world they're in
storage in a number of countries but
it's not necessary to transport it in
order to eliminate it because what's
important is to mix the uranium that is
they
they're the highly enriched uranium with
low grade uranium called depleted
uranium which there's a lot and by
mixing these together the material
becomes denatured and cannot be used for
weapons it cannot be restored to weapons
used without very sophisticated
equipment so that's an alternative which
means that you can just treat the
problem on site and not endanger
populations and the waters of the great
lakes with the possibility of a spill
which would be in fact extremely serious
we and caramel kilkenny was speaking
with gordon Edwards add the Canadian
Coalition for nuclear responsibility
[Music]
all right now both you guys probably
have seen various stories of the news
and so on about technology taking over
jobs you know robots on the assembly
lines and that means a lot of people
they're going to be announcers to write
well just about just about it I mean a
journalist well in fact it's true I mean
they're already our computer algorithms
that are writing news reports you know
and and sports reports and so a lot of
people you know maybe people who have
ordinary labor jobs or repetitive jobs
this is kind of thing that people in the
past i'm saying you know watch out your
job could be taken over by technology
but apparently what's going to happen
and in the near future is that
algorithms not robots but algorithms
computers are going to take over a lot
of white collar jobs including stuff
like lawyers and paralegals for example
yeah and this is not a good son this is
not a good sign I spoke with the guy
who's an expert at this his name is
Sunil Jo ha he's a policy director for
the moet center that's a public policy
think tank at the University of Toronto
and if this is an excerpt of course like
all of our items on the show so if you
want to hear the whole story you can go
to the website and this with the whole
story but in this extra few starts out
with just sort of a brief outline what's
happening that's so what we're seeing is
the advent of new forms of technology
artificial intelligence that's getting
just better and better by by V by the
month really and what that means is many
jobs that we historically would have
thought would never be at risk from
automation are becoming at risk so in
fields like investment banking and law
we're seeing computers that can actually
replace many of those tasks and the
question becomes then what happens to
the people who are doing those jobs or
they shunted into a more part-time role
or are they out of work and if if they
are to work how do we get them back into
the workforce and back into productive
roles this report says that a lot of
those white collar jobs as you've just
mentioned such as lawyers and
accountants and so on they're threatened
to so what
where are we going what what does
someone do is it gives a career choice I
think the key is people need to be
flexible and realized that what they are
going to school for today might not be
what they end up working as in two years
three years five years and those their
roles may change very rapidly within a
decade you might be doing three four or
five different things and the key is
really going to be how do we society how
to government how to corporations
develop the effective types of skills
training that get people in a position
where they can bounce from career to
career or job to job mr. Joe he'll give
me an example of some of the jobs that
we thought were pretty secure as a
career choice but which in fact again in
the relatively near future may not be
sure so I mean a great example is
Goldman Sachs back in two thousand they
had 600 cash equity traders on their us
desk in New York so I mean these are
highly paid professionals kind of people
you'd see in the movie wolf wolf of Wall
Street making a lot of money so there
were 600 of those people in two thousand
at Goldman Sachs there are two of them
today doing that job Goldman Sachs is
currently looking at how they can expand
automation artificial intelligence to
take over for many of their investment
banker so not just people making stock
trains with people structuring deals and
doing kind of these really highly
cognitive function so that's a great
example of a job that I don't think many
people would think would ever be
automated and those types of
white-collar Wall Street jobs are in
fact already being taken by computers if
everybody is sort of unemployed because
a robot has taken over their job or an
algorithm has taken over their job then
aren't we in kind of serious problems
yeah then we're really an uncharted
territory I mean who do we tax if not as
many people have well-paying jobs and
we're chasing after global corporations
that can shield their profits very
effectively so once again that's an
excerpt of my conversation with Sunil
Joe Hal of the moet Center a public
policy think tank at the University of
Toronto
very interesting some of the things that
he said in that interview for example is
if you're in college now the thing is
that our our university training has
sort of been directing people to be very
focused in their careers and I was like
ear you're going to go into this and
you're going to be like engineering and
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to be this and that and that you
saying if these jobs are replaced by
computers and algorithms all that
focused training is going to be no good
in the future because if there's going
to be a lot more part-time and temporary
work and you might do something here and
something completely different over
there and something next week somewhere
else you know they saying it really you
got to start looking at more generalized
training it's very very complicated very
interested or hands on stuff that cannot
be done by computers yeah or like oh I
can't be done by computers well they're
still not very good at creating stuff
that they can learn but they still don't
create stuff and who's going to replace
a brick wall or you know you do your
plumbing yeah well you know the
surprising thing is even in greenhouses
now you know they have they have
computers like robots in greenhouses
that can water the plants and take to
monitor them and everything oh it's very
complicated but think about this one of
the most common jobs for men in the
world is truck driver but Mercedes is
already experimenting with a giant
autonomous truck so what are you going
to do with like you know millions of
truck drivers feeling just as an example
and taxi drivers and so on wait hold it
and advising your future and we're not
really in the Far yeah driverless cars
are going to be on the road in two years
or something that well he's taught I'm
not getting in one but I have my own
reasons I like driving you know I don't
want some machine to serve you putter
around him anyway that's a very upbeat
story of people out there I hope you
enjoyed that story because we want to
put you in a good mood for the weekend
well done welcome next week on this
program robot will be you're listening
to the link online rci net CA and of
course via the german shortwave service
and on world radio paris and on facebook
and hello to cameroon who's watching us
right now
if you are watching us and drop us a
line and let us know or write to us on
Facebook let us know where you're you're
viewing us and we'd like to know these
things and say hello to you starting us
off on some of our letters this week and
comments post to our stories we had
several comments to a story called stop
punishing kids with ADHD attention
deficit disorder and we start with a
kind of a disturbing story from Patricia
okay so Patricia rights please share
this with principals school boards my
son has ADHD and is punished and blamed
for everything he has tried six
medications the school needs to have
strategies more behavioral text time and
empathy and most of all understanding
and how to manage our precious children
our school system has failed us and our
children it's embarrassing my son is
being bullied and after three months has
finally retaliate 'add through punching
and kicking what would he do now that's
part of a longer comment from Patricia
in laval quebec and another comment from
ashley i agree totally are they having a
almost eight year old and within three
weeks my son has been suspended off the
bus for threatening the bus driver and
if he does it again he's expelled from
the school he takes two meds 14 morning
and 14 afternoon and just four on the
bus and still gets suspended so what am
I supposed to do is his parent and to
ashley's called for health lake who
actually got an answer and this one came
from Natalie who is a school board
trustee in Ontario and she writes Ashley
depending the lamp school board your
child attends the often policies in
place that help protect your child's
legal rights to accommodation due to
diagnose medical neurological and or
developmental disorders for example at
whether Lou Ontario district school
board the procedure states that certain
behaviors of children with ADHD must not
be responded to as intentional or
purposeful violations of a code of
conduct not very many parents notice a
sort of policy procedure exists and they
don't know
how to leverage the information to get
the support that their child needs at
the school I totally understand your
frustration I to have a son 10 years old
with ADHD and Natalie suggests Ashley
contact her for more information on a
story about a new documentary film on
surrogate mothers Laura wrote tank
surrogacy is a gift for a lot of couples
struggling with infertility issues
thanks to all women who want to help
other people to become true to their
dream of parenthood and we had the 72nd
anniversary of our CI this week and
Jonathan Marx wrote LaVon for me RCA was
one of the few broadcasters on shortwave
with nude engaging programs giving
insights into science and technology
that you couldn't get elsewhere they put
Canada into context and really made an
effort to interact with audiences long
before anyone thought of the Internet
able it would be great if you could make
a 60 minute audio tribute to a service
that is still remembered and deserves
more than just a few photos and that
comment from Jonathan marks they just
say something here that show the link
was one of the best shows on television
that was produced by you and directed by
you and hosted by you and it's there's a
big gap on radio this reader is
absolutely right well you have to say it
was certainly well appreciated when it
was broadcast even even domestically on
CBC we got an awful lot of letters from
NASA said you know who listened to I
mean they can compare us to other shows
in the office right no I was a damn good
show yeah well anyway that was a comment
from Jonathan marks at Terry oh where
are we okay well we had another one from
Kyle oubli would you read that Terry yes
I will but i'm not sure what the
cutbacks in the 1990s that would be the
one yes okay the cutbacks in the 1990s
included the elimination of the german
service which from the german point of
view with the demise of our CI since all
attempts to save and later restore it
removed futile and very little from the
service remains besides the few seconds
from the last broadcast that can be seen
heard on the CBC TV report about the
whole massacre and I think it is
imperative to get the facts correct all
decisions in regard to the sack though
facility had according to all sources i
have seen been the sole matter of cbc
management for starters the very
disproportionate savings at rci in 2012
compared to the volume of the general
budget cut had been the internal
decision of the cbc the government only
chose to not object to this approach all
right that comments on an article about
the anniversary in history of our FBI on
the 72nd anniversary which was this week
well and one more memory posted to the
story of the film on the destruction of
our CI antennas and the transmitter site
and this from grant Hibs lemond i was on
my way back from Prince Edward Island
when we were welcome to visit the
transmitter site I was super thrilled I
was on site one months before
disposition closed the download
heatsinks with the size of a small
warehouse they had Harry's tube
transmitters really occurred in the
walls there was so much more potential
for this site package radio in a time of
crisis I sure hope my iphone is charged
the site is gone now sad and that's a
comment from grab grant hibbs who had a
chance to visit the transmitter site
before it closed when our CI is not gone
we're still here but we are in a
melancholy mood today when you put this
show together she's not a logarithm is
in the demise of our CI well done Mon
come and have a good day everybody and
once again will be replaced by computer
place that camera with a computer all
right we've had several stories about
one of the world's only flying world war
two lancaster bombers and about another
that's been sitting outside at a small
airport in edmundston New Brunswick
which has been slowly deteriorating for
years and I've actually written a number
of reports on that one it's called kb
882 it is finally going to be taken to
the National Air Museum in Trenton
Ontario this summer and tidied up
although sadly it won't fly again but
jim morgan wrote this terry i served in
the rcaf in the 1960s i am thrilled the
lancaster at the edmonds airport will be
restored
I have visited it several times on
visiting Nova Scotia good luck and on a
story finally about the cost to bring
Syrian refugees to Canada Glen Coombs
wrote this let's pray and hope the
Trudeau is in power for a short of time
as possible for all the people that
worried him in next time use common
sense because we have gained nothing and
are losing so much all right that
political comment it is not our comment
all right we're just anything that I
really feel good all right that did for
our comments for this week remember you
can comment on any story on the website
just scroll down to the very bottom of
the page and each on each story and the
space is there well it's time for a bit
of Canadian music and KD Lang is
originally from Alberta she's going on
tour this summer yes she's great yeah
did you oh you know I was thinking she
you you've heard the song of her with
Roy Orbison crying yeah that's yet she
claims she's also on that that that
video was Roy Orbison and everybody and
Springsteen and was Springsteen another
finishing with Chuck Berry that that
that it's about a 25-minute video of
them singing and Bonnie Raitt singing
backup and so is so is Cady it's a great
if you ever see it one hour thinking of
what's with her and Roy Orbison singing
his song crime and and it's just it's
just great she she just anyway she's
great I'm maintaining voice she's on
tour this summer she's going to
Australia and then right across Canada
she's calling the tour and as your new
Redux because it's the 25th anniversary
of her hit album engine my god really
it's 25 years that's quickly from that
album you're suppressing me I am or
something yes the music room it's called
miss chatelaine
[Music]
I was
just again just a kid
[Music]
why become just a small
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
ah
[Music]
be good
miss
[Music]
Michele
there you go from Alberta KD Lang Roth
order Katie and you know what she
doesn't she doesn't remember when she
first became popular she's a vegetarian
he comes from Alberta and everybody
really got on her case all that the meat
producers got under case she says no
sorry this is this is what I this is
what I believe back off you know that
was in her cow Punk days her cow hunk a
boy can she sing oh she was great even
you know when she started out she had
this whole genre that was brand-new this
cow Punk things sort of like country but
punkish and I was here but she evolved
into this beautiful crooner in a torch
singer Oh tremendous stuff anyway she's
onto her a check if you're on Australia
she'll be coming and then later on in
September she starts across Canada so
she's going to a lot of sites in Canada
so good for her yeah her she says
everything she gets all right we're
gonna rock in this next really oh yeah
whoa but we're gonna go back in history
of months you can't rock a familiar
tango you know it seems incongruous but
he's gonna run up head ways you can I
think if you show us your tango classes
oh that's right yeah we'll have to play
tango music one day not now all right
let's get into the rocks here you're
going to go travel the audience they're
going to go way way way way way back
right wait 60 million years back to be
more precise even before Terry's time
and believe it or not believe it or not
in geological terms this is young yeah
so I have a question for us Gigi you
guys collected Mama's gonna be a test
yeah science study when you were kids
did you collect the rocks i pick up some
nice little cute rocks you know I did
yeah so my mind to you her name is
Hannah Caruso did this is how she
started she when she was going to go up
in Mexico on her family trips she would
pick up a lot of rocks and carry them
home and drive her mom crazy well today
she is a professor of geology at the
University of Quebec and Montreal or you
can as it's known in French and she's
the published research that shows
that the 16 million year old rocks from
the Canadian Arctic are basically
rewriting the early history of our
planet and the moon and the reason is
this is kind of counterintuitive but
this young rocks they carrying them
particles from very deep inside the
Earth's mantle and they were you know
brought up why this huge volcanoes and
this information tells us about the
origins of the earth and the moon let's
listen to another explanation the most
accepted hypothesis that we have on the
mood formation is that the moon was
created through a giant impact this
giant impact should have melted big
portions of the earth maybe the whole
mantle the idea and a couple of years
ago was that a asteroid of the size of
Mars hit the earth and then the ejectors
after this collision got trapped into
the gravity of our planet and then came
together to form the moon now finding
parts of the mountain that haven't
melted because of this impact tell us
that this giant I was not as China as we
thought but maybe just a smaller object
smaller than Mars that hit the earth but
rather with a very energetic way so we
have questions about how the planet
works today that we can try to figure
out because of what we're finding in
these rocks but also how the planet was
formed and how the planet was formed
with the moon howl the moon was formed
so finding very old parts inside years
that have survived since since it's very
beginnings has very important
implications for the history of our
planet and even for the history of the
moon well that was an excerpt of my
conversation with University of Quebec
in Montreal
geologists chanukah rizzo and these
rocks were found by mcgill university
professor Don Francis in southeastern
back in Ireland and working in this
remote part of the Arctic is a huge
challenge so for researchers like Rizzo
and they rely on the help and support of
local Inuit communities and r is also
talked to me about the importance of
English tradition illallah Jin her
research and the importance of using
image place names so we're extremely
happy and extremely lucky to be able to
work with the Inuit communities the
different new communities and we have a
lot of respect for their land and we
work with the rocks of an inland so we
always try to let them know what we're
doing sometimes we can organize little
courses of why we're so interested as
geologists of these rocks let them know
that we're not interested in looking for
a go which is most of the times what
people think or diamonds but rather
because these rocks are old and they can
tell us information about how our planet
was formed so we try to let them know
what we're doing and also we adopt as
much as possible the their knowledge for
example in places where we collect the
samples we gave we as units how how does
this place what's the name of this place
how can we call this place and so we
always try to in our scientific
publications to add the Inuit language
of the places where we take the rocks so
it's not just a hill number this but
usually this place is having it place
names yes and and the things that when
we look at the maps there's a lot of
places that do not have the names
anymore so they have an English name or
a German name in function of how the
unions were displaced at some point but
they have in it names there's this
curves and there's mountains and they
all have names because like in northern
level
sample people were leaving there so yes
instead of getting just a name of the
hill or an English name or GPS
coordinates we try to participate with
them as much as possible and give the
image of the different places were we
have taken the rocks because it's their
land that was an excerpt of my
conversation with University of Quebec
and Montreal geologists chanukah rizzo
and you can read the whole report either
on the Iron the Arctic website or on our
website Carrie how many how many any
what are their you I know you work on
the Arctic in your very you've had a lot
of action up there how many you know the
population it's difficult to say well
there's four english regions in canada
so you have about sorry i think 35 to 50
thousand in no no wood and smaller
regions in nov i looked in nunavik in
quebec and not see a route in northern
love of water alright and on that note
we're almost at a time for the show for
today so now for now carry yes who it
yet Terry are you here yes well it says
here Terry sorry but it's what heaven is
amazing a blank I said as far as I get
I've been replaced it was like well look
at my script here this and LaVon savant
and webmaster off-screen Leo and our
technician who is completely honest that
we have to get a camera to get a shot of
you once well so you can wait oh no no
no I don't want that okay it get Leo on
camera okay right there can you get leo
yes you can see him alright so tune in
next week at the same time same place
for more action adventure here on the
link the only one I get to Pratt lives
not to algorithmic or robotics we
haven't been related by a computer yet
so far take care until next week bye bye
ha